so what is the new policy you've
introduced today British cycling have
published two new policies firstly a
competitive policy that sees the
creation of an open category and the
definition of the female category uh
designated female assets by birth we
also then have a non-competitive policy
that is completely inclusive so two key
principles for us in getting to this
point first of all on the competitive
policy based and predicated on furnace
and the second policy based on
inclusivity accessibility and being open
for all what's changed now why is do we
need to change the policy it's taking us
some time to get to this point and we do
acknowledge that in the suspension of
the policy we have created some
uncertainty today's boat showing parity
readership in clear direction we have
taken consultation we have listened to
Riders from across the cycling Community
we have looked at the available medical
research and we've also taken a view
from a legal perspective and considering
all of those different things that's The
Waiting day that we've got to this
policy renounced with implementation to
follow do you fear legal challenges
we cannot predict uh the future what we
need to do is what's right for British
cycling for a cycling Community uh
predicated on those two principles of
furnace and inclusivity um so we're very
confident in the work that we've
undertaken it's been incredibly thorough
it's taken some time to get to the point
and that's why today we're publishing uh
the two new policies the science isn't
certain so why go against inclusivity
we've looked at a range of different
masses in getting to this point so first
of all is to consult with our athletes
secondly is to look at the scientific
research that is available at this point
in time and thirdly is from a legal
perspective
we want to move forward we want to use
Clarity we want to give direction we
want to remove the uncertainty and
certainly the athletes have been
affected by this uncertainty created
over the past few months
um I'm really sorry for the anxiety for
the upset and for uh that they have been
affected by getting to this point today
was her favorite boycott by female
Riders
but we we consider all of the different
options we can't predict the future
um but what we what we're determined to
do is do our best for the athletes
currently in the GB system for the
athletes who are looking to competing um
Great Britain cycling organized events
and also for athletes that want to
compete and enjoy recreational Leisure
cycling so it is the whole spectrum of
the cycling community that we are
concentrating on in focus and that's why
we've made this decision
some might say this is discriminatory
we we have taken um a view uh that this
is absolutely about being inclusive for
all we've created a new open category
that anyone has the ability to ride in
and offer a non-competitive policy that
is absolutely inclusive and accessible
um we will not tolerate any form of
discrimination in moving forward with
this policy and it's really important
that we support we empathize we are
compassionate to the riders that are
affected by this policy change are you
now denying Emily Bridges a chance of
qualifying for the Olympics
Emily and a number of athletes are
clearly affected by this policy but what
we wanted to provide at this point in
time is The Clarity on the direction of
travel the decision that we've made on
behalf of British cycling for the whole
of the cycling community
it's obviously a very divisive issue how
hard was it to come to this conclusion
it's very difficult it's divisive it's
emotive it's affecting human beings and
we absolutely fully understand and
appreciate that so it has been a
difficult process it has taken some time
but we wanted to do it diligently
properly and get to this position that
we have done today how many are affected
by this
that there are a small number of riders
that are directly affected and impacted
um we have reached out we have tried to
involve everyone across the cycling
community in the consultation uh work
that we've undertaken and we will also
continue to support the Riders directly
affected at this point in time it is
small in number but also clearly big in
impact and that's why today we want to
make sure that we're showing empathy
compassion also Clarity in some of the
direction how complicated is that the
UCI is the world governing body they've
not come to their position yet we we
respect the uci's position we have been
in dialogue with the UCI for a number of
weeks and we acknowledge that UCI are in
a review process and we'll make another
announcement in August but today is
about British recycling it's about what
is right for us and our cycling
Community predicated on furnace and
inclusivity did you see any argument
actually to continue allowing trans
women to compete in female categories we
looked at every available option and
that's why the consultation was
incredibly important to listen to not
just directly impacted but to listen to
the rest of the cycling Community an
overlap with the medical evidence that's
available at this point in time thanks a
lot thank you